all right guys so we are having a first
impressions with the all-new Nikon ZF
now people have been asking for a full
frame Retro Camera since the zfc came
out and I was one of those people I was
like why don't we have a full frame
camera system because the 28 F 2.8 that
they released was a full-frame lens with
an aps-c body so
in my mind I was thinking there must be
something in development and yes we have
it right here and it's called the ZF now
attached to it I have the 40 millimeter
F2 by the way this is a fantastic lens
and this is the special edition retro
style lens on it absolutely love it
we're going to diver deeper into this
camera system to talk to you about if
this is the right camera for you
especially because this is a full-frame
retro camera or would you want to opt
for let's say the Z8 z72 z62 let's get
down to it
before we kick things off I do want to
let you know we're not paid or sponsor
for this video but Nikon has been kind
enough to loan us a pre-production unit
of the ZF so I am not going to give you
a full review on this this is the first
impressions because firmware is not
Final on this we cannot shoot in raw
format as of yet only jpeg so the images
you'll be seeing throughout this video
will be as such but I just want to let
you guys know that okay so let's talk
about some of the highlights of this
camera system you know I'm on the
Facebook group so I'm on the forums I'm
on watching YouTube videos just like you
guys are so many of you been asking what
are we getting a z63 when is this camera
coming this is essentially that z63 the
ZF is arguably better than the z62 in
any way shape or form except minus the
CF Express xqd card slot that's really
the only difference in the course if you
like that more traditional SLR look then
you might go for the z62 but in terms of
specs and functionality and performance
this camera trumps it in a big big way
let's talk about some of the features
inside of it you have the X speed 7
processor the same processor that's in
the Z8 and z9 is now in the ZF that
means your auto focusing 3D tracking all
that's included in this you have various
different shapes you can just set for
your auto focusing up to 77 different
variable scenarios it's nuts you're not
going to set all that but it's there in
the camera if you want to do that
subject detection animal people all
that's there if you're using if you use
the z9 and a Z8 and you're used to that
auto focusing system that's all brought
in here to the ZF which is awesome to
use especially in a retro camera look in
addition to this you have have improved
Ibis up to eight stops but for the most
part it's gonna be seven stops only
certain lenses with VR will give you
eight stops of image stabilization
inside the camera system but we'll have
there'll be a list I believe on Nick on
site when it's launched so you can check
that out see if your lens does follow
fall into that category but for the most
part I would say seven stops much better
than the previous five stops that Nikon
had on the Z6 and z72 ISO is now from
000. so this is more than enough for
most people out there I know some
companies like to say 200 300 000 for is
open nobody ever shoots that it's just
more
um flexing their muscles so to speak
sixty four thousand will you ever get to
that hard to say but a 24 megapixel
sensor with good low light performance
is more than adequate for most Shooters
out there so uh yes your Baseline is 100
though so keep that in mind
also a new feature of this camera which
I think a lot of you will like is if
let's say you're looking through the evf
instead of using a joystick to move your
auto focusing point or your single
output point of autofocus whatever it
may be you can now use the display now
how it works is uh you set inside the
menu and you just use your thumb to move
it around on the display now it doesn't
automatically auto focus when you select
onto the subject you're still going to
have to press the shutter release or
whatever button you have assigned
throttle Focus to lock focus on but you
can move the point by the display this
is a pre-production so I'm not gonna get
too deep into it it works relatively
well but I'm guessing with the uh
production firmware it'll be even
smoother but I have to say for the most
part
it's very useful and I think a lot of
people will enjoy it especially with the
larger display on the back of this
one feature to this camera system that I
think a lot of people are going to enjoy
especially if you are into video
a full-frame camera system with a flip
out rotatable display the first of its
kind that Nikon has brought into a
full-frame camera
taking them a long time to do it but
they brought into the ZF and hopefully
they bring into a z92 or z82 because I
would love to see that this makes
shooting videos so much easier speaking
of video let's talk about that right now
up to 4K 60 but you're getting a crop at
4K 60 a 1.5 crop think of it like super
35 but if you want to do 4K 30 4K 25 4K
24 full width of the sensor fhd at 120
you're not gonna be able to shoot in Raw
on this but how many people shoot in raw
but you can I believe shoot with f-log
so if you want to shoot a log you can do
that as well one of the key features to
the ZM is black and white
it's a switch on the camera so you can
go from video
to photo to black and white monochrome
baby now again it's jpeg
you can shoot this in rock you've used
the Nikon software it'll import as a
black and white that you convert it to
color if you want but you can shoot
black and white very very easily on this
absolutely love it I'm shooting half of
my photos in black and white because
everything looks better in black and
white it's awesome you can dial it in
you can you can tweak the black and
white a little bit however you want it
to be but it's a welcome attribute and
it kind of just adds the whole retro
feel of this camera card slots you have
two of them now you have a micro SD and
you have a UHS two card slot now there's
been discussion about these two card
slots here's my theory on this right
first and foremost that the micro SD
card is meant to be a card that stays in
your camera think of it like internal
storage and use it as such so whatever
size you want 32 64 128 you can keep it
inside your camera your uhs2 card you
can take that out as in win because a
lot more cameras nowadays are using
internal storage to sort of help
photographers along the way and you can
use it even as a backup that's about how
I'd use the micro SD card but then you
have uhs2 do I wish to receive Express
type B I kind of do but again this is
not a pro camera like the Z8 or z9 or
the z72 or z62 in that regard but it's
relatively fast in terms of the the
reader write speeds on it so no issues
at all but do take in mind that micro SD
I would leave it in the camera I think
that's a brilliant move by Nikon okay
let's talk about body design it's taking
me a while hasn't it yes it has because
I have a zfc
now I have in my hands the ZF
are there differences oh yeah night and
day the zfc is a very lightweight Retro
Camera it's smaller in size it's it's a
great camera for someone who's getting
into digital photography or someone just
wants a nice lightweight kid to walk
around travel with it just disappears in
your back
but the build quality some people say I
wish it was a little bit I wish it was
like the Nikon film cameras that I get
you I have an fm3 I think it's built
like a tank at an f3hp too by the way
how to sell it that's another story for
another day but
Nikon's cameras have always built been
built beautifully especially in the
Retro that lineup right now the ZF has
that build quality like I'm used to
using out of a film camera right I put
my FM 3A next to this bad boy oh man I'm
in glorious Heaven this is beautiful
it's built like a tank it's solid metal
construction you're gonna have some
plastic bits here and there but for the
most part it feels really good it's got
some nice way to exclusive that's gonna
help with stabilization for video and
for photography as well but I gotta tell
you it is built beautifully now it's a
little thicker it's a bit bigger than
the zfc granite's a full frame sensor
versus aps-c but
absolutely love it now
there's a little bit of a grip here
you're going to notice on the side
versus the zfc which was completely flat
you got to get it an additional grip I
got that from Japan because I think on
Singapore you guys don't sell the
extended grip I had to buy it from Japan
on eBay they're here with me watching
the video gotta bring that grip in
anyway it's a great grip you can order
from eBay from Japan Nikon Japan they'll
send it over to you but this one has the
grip built in inside of it and this is
really good especially when you can be
using larger lenses because as we know
there's the 40 millimeter F2 SE lens
here and the 28 F 2.8 that comes with
the zfc oh
you see what happens when we got the
Nikon reps here
we've got the small rig grip by the way
small rig collaborating with Nikon once
again and you've got a grip for the ZF
that will be launched at Market as well
look at that bad boy it's a little bit
different than what we're feeling on the
ZF
but this is more tactile especially in
our hot humid climate in Singapore I'm
loving this grip and getting back to the
lenses these are the two smallest lenses
that you have for the Retro lineup the
40f2 and the 22.8 I'm hoping Nikon does
come out with a F2 lineup let's say 50
35 75 kind of a retro AIS vibe to the
lenses like these would be awesome but I
would highly recommend if you're using
the 24 to 70 or 2.8 or the F4 or any
other primes of the 51.2 Glorious lens
one of the best 50s on the market hands
down that you get the grip because these
are longer lenses
and
I can't put it on just yet but you know
it's gonna feel absolutely awesome
you're gonna need that grip for those
lenses if you want to shoot super
telephoto with this well you can
just work out a little bit more let's
get a little bit beyond but it'll work
out but overall
that's the design absolutely awesome the
evf on the back of it of course got a
little bit of a rubber eye cup here
where the zfc was plastic a little bit
harder plastic much more comfortable to
the eye to use I love using an evf I'm
more traditional that way and I am very
very happy with that now in terms of the
ports on the side micro HDMI
I know why do people use micro HDMI in
it is what it is I wish it was full size
cameras up a little bit larger but I
don't think you're gonna be using HDMI
to record on this camera for the most
part you're probably this is more of a
run and Gun kind of carry camera but it
is what it is you still have HDMI access
USB C is your charge via about if you
want to do that as well
um your mic headphone jack all that's
included in this so no issues at all
with that so that pretty much wraps up
my thoughts here on the camera in terms
of the specs what's inside of it there's
a lot more in terms of the finer
features of this camera system but you
can read the website for that but anyway
what I'm going to do is I'm going to get
up Zachy we're gonna take some shots
and if you're thinking I was in a set
the whole time no
we're in the middle of a street
or a sidewalk here in Singapore we've
moved this around because the shop is
closed today their opening hours are
Monday to Saturday 7 A.M to 3 P.M it's
F1 weekend here so we decided to use
their workbench
and keep it real we keep it raw for you
anyway before we go show you some photos
quick message from our sponsor this
video is brought to you by MSI meet the
summit E6 then flip
7 processor RTX 30 series graphics and a
16 inch Quad HD Plus touchscreen panel
with a 360 degree hinge it lets you
unleash maximum productivity with up to
11 hours of battery life at just 2
kilograms the summit e16 flip offers
unprecedented performance and
functionality allowing you to work and
play anywhere anytime
[Music]
foreign
so final thoughts on this camera as you
saw from the sample photos and some of
the video footage here it's it's a good
camera
um
it's a 24 megapixel we've seen this type
of image quality coming out of Nikon's
cameras before it's really good very
sharp great colors got the Nikon color
science which we all love
but I have to say I was pleasantly
surprised using it for the brief time
I've had it just how feature-rich this
camera is I mean I thought when they the
rumors were coming out that they were
going to announce a full frame camera
system like this it was going to be
limited it was going to be handicapped
it was just gonna be about the looks and
not much else this is a camera as I
mentioned from the beginning of this
video essentially a z63
improved video functionality improved
Auto focusing
improved specs all the way through you
have the same processor the Z8 and z9
and it delivers yes it's a
pre-production things are not final yet
things will be improved but I can tell
you from my first impression standpoint
I think it's going to sell very very
well the only thing Nikon needs to do
now is actually make more lenses to
match the style of body because as we
know their full frame lenses are quite
large and they may not fit ergonomically
this 40f2 does well the 28 2.8 does well
but it'd be nice to have them let's say
do an F2 lineup retro AIS look to them
50 35 75 even at 24 I think it would do
very well for a lot of people out there
and maybe even a smaller Zoom but uh
remains to be seen I mean let me know
your thoughts in the comment section
below what do you guys think of this
camera system you're gonna pick it up
are you on the fence love to hear from
you guys anyway those are my thoughts on
the all new Nikon ZF and if you like
this camera review check out more of our
reviews right here